Kim Kardashian wears nothing but glitter  to plug her makeup line her body really  is the accessory the 37 year old reality  star took to Instagram on Monday to  promote her new line of k'kaw beauty  products posing in the buff drenched in  gold glitter I'm so curb even if I try  to like put other things on and I look  like a joke the Mogul stripped down and  worked it for the camera rocking silver  locks in a high ponytail and a  strategically placed arm perfect  Kim captioned the shot quote ultra light  beams highlighters and glosses launching  December 1st on k'kaw beauty calm  coincidentally Kim's husband rapper  Kanye West has a song titled ultra light  beam and the Keeping Up star shared a  behind-the-scenes clip from the  photoshoot on her app featuring her  hubby's tune when you're on the ocean  light beam this is a guy dream this is a  car dream this is everything